وهذه الصور هي من باريس حيث هذه
الاحتجاجات ما زالت مستمره وهناك بعض
المواجهات بين الشرطه والمحتجين طبعا هذه
الاحتياجات خرجت منذ اسابيع ردا على سن
التقاعد او رفضا ايضا على موضوع رفع سن
التقاعد في فرنسا
ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
للشرطه الفرنسيه التي
تحاول ان تفرق المتظاهرين في باريس هذه
الاحتياجات ما زالت مستمره طيله هذا اليوم
في باريس وعدد من المدن الفرنسيه
وايضا هناك هذه المظاهرات ما زالت مستمره
منذ اسابيع حيث ان المتظاهرين مازالوا
متمسكين بمطلبهم تجاه موضوع سن التقاعد
بينما الحكومه والرئيس الفرنسي ايضا ما
زالوا مصرين على قرارهم حتى ان الرئيس
الفرنسي كان ذكر بان هذا القرار لن يعود
عنه حتى ولو افقده الكثير من شعبيته ما
زلنا نتابع هذه الصور من باريس
للمتظاهرين الذين ما يزال هنا متواجدين
الاعداد هي بالعشرات كما نتابع ومنذ قليل
ايضا في هذه الصوره كنا تابعنا تواجد كثيف
للشرطه الفرنسيه
المتواجده في الشوارع في باريس لمواجهه
هذه التظاهرات